supergirl is getting a new look for
season five and it's as much a matter of
practicality as it is of fashion the new
look was unveiled to fans at San Diego
comic-con in the series star Melissa
Benoist had a hilarious explanation for
fans she's tired of freezing her lights
off Supergirl aka Kara Danvers has
undergone a few slight tweaks to her
wardrobe during the show's run most
notably during season 4's climactic
battle with Jon Cryer's lex luthor and
the red daughter that costume switch may
have been born of necessity but car's
new look seems to be more of a direct
fashion statement and evolution of her
classic costume that aligns a little
more closely with the aesthetic of her
famous cousin Superman the biggest
difference
according to Benoist she and the series
producers simply figured that it was
time for a little update but has been
moist told Entertainment Tonight there
was another reason for the switch as
well that reason has to do with the fact
that Supergirl shoots primarily in
Vancouver Canada and often in the dead
of winter then we moved to Vancouver and
it was cold and it feels right it feels
like the good like the right evolution
and the right time to do it
although Benoist has acquitted herself
spectacularly in the role of Supergirl
it's now apparent that her performance
has actually been even better than she's
been given credit for if you've ever
tried to play it off as if you're not
extremely uncomfortable while freezing
your tail off you know that it's darn
near impossible for that matter kudos to
the cast of the rest of the air / series
which also shoots in Vancouver during
those months when the weather will
pretty much kill you if you're exposed
to it for too long may however have at
least gotten to our pants for the
duration of their show's runs in
addition to cars new look Supergirl
season 5 will also feature a decidedly
distinct aesthetic from season 4 which
saw the Girl of Steel thwarting Luthor's
plans to sow discord between the human
and alien populations of Earth the
season carried some obvious political
overtones and while the themes explored
in season 5 will be much different they
will be just as topical comic-con fans
were treated to a special preview of the
new batch of episodes which will deal
with society's deepening reliance
on technology with executive producer
Robert Rovner going so far as to call it
the show's black mirror season karo will
also have to deal with the wrath of her
friend and Lex Luthor's sister Lina who
was pretty unhappy to discover that cara
had been hiding her secret identity from
her for their entire relationship the
trailer also confirmed that Lex Luthor
who had been shot and left for dead by
Lena was indeed rescued from his fate by
the monitor he'll be back to Menace her
hero in the new season season 5 has also
added a few interesting supporting
characters including Veronica Mars as
julie Gonzalo as Andrea Rojas a
businesswoman with super heroic
aspirations joining her will be Game of
Thrones Staz NER as william day a
hard-boiled reporter hiding his
connections to the criminal underworld
finally being humans Meaghan Rath will
portray a female Brainiac 5 joining her
real-life brother Jesse Rath who
portrayed a male Brainiac 5 and previous
seasons we'll see how all of the
intrigue and interdimensional weirdness
plays out as well as how Supergirl
Season 5 might connect to the big crisis
on Infinite Earths crossover slated for
this winter when the new episodes began
airing on the CW on October 6 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]